[Music]  we have a saying  in asgard where there are wolf's ears  wolves teeth and ear it's a trap  he's lying just playing games at me for  a sec loki  my ears are sharp too  here's the deal fugitive variant's been  killing our minutemen  we haven't been able to find them so  let's bring in an expert  that's me the criminal could be anywhere  we got to anytime careful anything we do  can impact the course of history you get  that  okay  the timekeepers are monitoring every  aspect of this case  trusting this man is not a good idea  no one bad is ever truly bad  and no one good is ever truly good  this isn't about you right  [Music]  okay  i believe stupidly you can be  whatever you want to be even someone  good  by the way i should have an equal amount  of security this is insulting you just  can't help yourself  [Music]  you